hey everyone thanks for tuning in
today i wanted to talk to you about web
assembly
what it is
why it's awesome
and how you can start using it in your
own web applications
so let me start by introducing myself so
my name is robert buchaliel and my
background is a mix of software
engineering and bioinformatics
i'm the maintainer of
the library bioasm so this is a
collection
of bioinformatics tools that we've
pre-compiled to webassembly and are
hosting for free on cdn
so that
other bioinformatics web apps can make
use of it
i'm also the author of the book level up
with webassembly so if you're just
getting started with webassembly feel
free to check it out
all right so what is webassembly anyway
well i like to think of webassembly as
really just being yet another language
that you can use in the browser
alongside javascript html and css
now to give you a sense for what this
language looks like
let's take a look at a
simple example
here i'm defining a function
called
hello
and all this function does is return the
string openjs world
now
you don't need to know anything about
webassembly just looking at this
you can tell this is not a language that
you probably want to code
and that's good because you don't have
to
in fact the whole idea of webassembly is
that you can take code written in other
languages and compile that
down to webassembly
and so that's why it's called a
compilation target because you take code
written in these other languages compile
it to webassembly and then you run it in
the browser
so where is webassembly actually useful
though well here are a few
use cases
one is code reuse
you know all these applications i'm
showing here
are very large
code bases
hundreds of thousands millions of lines
of code
where webassembly was
really essential to let them transition
these
apps from running on a desktop or in a
command line onto the web without having
to rewrite everything in javascript so
this is very convenient from the code
reusability perspective
the other big use case is performance
so in in these four applications what
they've done is
look at the most compute intensive part
of their apps that were written in
javascript
and replace those
with webassembly
and what they noticed was
a large speed up
and better performance
now of course so i know this is not
guaranteed to work right just because
you use webassembly does not mean that
your app will always be faster but for a
certain category
of data intensive applications
it
can help
the other use case behind webassembly is
portability
so
the idea here is that you can also use
webassembly outside the browser
really anywhere where you can find a web
assembly runtime that can execute your
code
you can have webassembly and so here i'm
showing for examples
for example cloudflare and fastly these
are providing
serverless functions that run
webassembly at the edge
the nice thing about using webassembly
for serverless is that they initialize a
lot faster
and are cheaper
because webassembly
you know is more a lot more lightweight
than using containers for example
you can also run webassembly on your
server if you use
runtimes like wasmtime wasmer or even
nodejs right can run webassembly
you can also run your webassembly
binaries on raspberry pi
as shown in this
screenshot from from the wasm 3 team
which also build a webassembly runtime
so all these
use cases look great
but can you actually use it today
and the answer is yes
about 93 percent
of users on the web today are running
browsers that support webassembly and so
this is great news
one thing that's interesting though is
you know how many developers actually
use webassembly and so to get a sense
for that what we can do is look at the
state of javascript this is a survey
that is done every year
they pull 20 000 javascript developers
and one of the questions they ask
is are you familiar with webassembly and
so here are the results
about 75
of developers who answered this survey
know what webassembly is but had not had
a chance to use it
15
had never heard of it and only about 10
of the respondents for that survey
said that they had actually used
webassembly
so
you know we only have two data points
here 2019 and 2020 for the percentage
of developers who have used webassembly
around 10
but
if we're interested in projecting future
webassembly usage
what we can do is use
very sophisticated mathematical modeling
techniques
to try to
impute
what is the usage going to be
in the future and so what we can see is
by 2047
over 100
of javascript developers will be using
webassembly
now you know i'm kidding of course
that's not how anything works uh but it
will be
interesting to see
how that number actually plays out over
time
all right now what i'd like to do is
concretely give you two examples
of applications that i had the chance to
work on
where web assembly was really useful
both in terms of
performance
and code reuse
so the first one is fastq bio
this is an interactive web tool
that lets the user
input dna sequencing data and rapidly
evaluate the quality of that data
while the data stays inside the browser
so when we set out to build this we kind
of looked around and there were several
tools that could help
calculate these statistics that we're
interested in but none of them were
written in javascript right so we have
one in c c plus and java
and you know the time
that i built this i hadn't really heard
of webassembly so we figured the only
options
were
number one
host one of these tools on a server
and expose an api that lets you
make custom queries to that tool
and
you know while we could have done that
that gets expensive real fast especially
if you have a lot of users and you need
to scale it up
it's also problematic because you need
to make sure
that it's secure
and it doesn't accidentally let users
execute arbitrary commands on your
servers and start mining bitcoin um but
also there's a data upload issue right
you know the main use case
for this application
was to analyze files that were already
on the user's local computer
and so this
would be inconvenient
to have them uploading the data to the
cloud before they can
even analyze it
so the the second approach would be
let's rewrite a part of these tools
in javascript
a few problems there as well one this
takes time obviously
number two it's error prone right
anytime you're rewriting
a complex algorithm
that has edge cases
you're gonna
likely introduce errors
the other thing is
that we're now maintaining a separate
copy
of this tool written in a different
language and so we won't be benefiting
from all the updates and all the bug
fixes and new features that get added
onto
those original tools
so
despite the
uh
the challenges we ended up going
with option number two so we rewrote a
small portion of the tool ctk
in javascript
and it worked
however uh then i came across
webassembly
and that's when the third option opened
up
and this is really where
webassembly shines like these are all
existing tools
that are written in
in languages other than javascript
that we can now compile to webassembly
and run directly in the browser so not
only
do we get to run it in the browser but
there's also no need
to
rewrite any of the code so we get the
best of both worlds
but what's interesting here is also that
on top of the code reuse
that we got we also saw
some performance improvements
so what we are able to do is actually
speed up the app by 20x
by switching to webassembly from our
javascript implementation
so if you want all the details for this
you can check out my perf matters 2019
talk at
on youtube
all right case study number two so this
is an app that's called ribbon
it's an interactive tool
lets you explore complex rearrangements
in genomes
part of this application
involves parsing a special
bioinformatics binary file format
and
to do this parsing
we have a few existing tools that we can
use written c and rus you know again
this is
very often the case in bioinformatics by
the way where a lot of the tools are
written in c and c plus plus and rest
and so on
and so here we kind of end up with the
same situation right in terms of
implementation
do we host the tool on a server
probably not same issues as before with
the cost of security and you know
uploading the data to the cloud
the other option being
rewriting it
this time however
it won't take us much time because
someone else
had actually already rewritten
portions of of samtools in javascript
and so we just ended up using that
but after the success that we saw with
fastq bio we figured well let's try
webassembly here as well
and so what we saw
was again interestingly enough we saw a
two to three x
improvement in terms of runtime
but probably even more important than
that we're we're now
able to reuse a hundred thousand lines
of very complicated c code
that parses unique genomics file formats
and what's really nice about that is
that we're now able
to use features
that are available in the c library but
were not implemented in the javascript
one
for example we can now do a very quick
check
on the validity of the file formats
we can down sample the data randomly to
reduce the amount of memory that we're
using and how much compute we need on
the user's computer
and
all these
are only possible because we're just
relying on the off the shelf tool that
we've compiled to webassembly
all right
so if
you're building
these kinds of data intensive web apps
there are several interesting tools that
you can use
with webassembly and one is threads you
know obviously a lot of tools
use threads to speed up execution
and webassembly does support threads
using webworkers
and
the way that
shared memory is implemented between
threads is using this thing called
shared
array buffer
however
with
the spectrum malware that showed up
around 2018
what happened was that browsers ended up
turning off support for shared array
buffer
until relatively recently
and so you know a few years later
we're still at about 70 percent
of users running browsers that support
shared arraybuffer
so you know we're getting there but
we're not
quite all the way there and so for if
you are using threads
it's probably a good idea to use
feature detection
where you
test does the user support shared array
buffer
then use webassembly with threads
otherwise use the version of the
webassembly binary that does not have
threading in
it another really powerful tool is simdi
so cimd stands for single instruction
multiple data
and the idea is that this is
a way to parallelize code that is very
commonly used in data analysis image
processing
and so on
and so the idea is as the name suggests
you can process multiple data sets
within a single cpu
instruction so just to give you a very
concrete example let's say you have
points in a three-dimensional space
and you're interested in calculating the
distance between these points using this
formula
so here what you could do
is calculate
these three subtractions
one after the other
therefore taking up about three cpu
instructions
or
you could use sim d
and add
and insert those coordinates in an extra
large cpu register that can fit four of
these numbers at a time
and do the same for the second data
point
and then what you can do is use a cmd
instruction
that will subtract
all three coordinates within
a single cpu instruction
so obviously this has a lot of potential
for speeding up the calculation which is
why it's it's so commonly used
in a lot of mathematical and data
analysis heavy tasks
and the reason why i mention cmd is
because there is a webassembly simdi
proposal
currently focused on 128 bit registers
for most browsers
this isn't actually supported unless you
enable a flag but it will be enabled by
default
in chrome 91.
now i recently
did a test drive of webassembly simd
what i wanted to do was essentially
align dna sequences to a reference
genome and benchmark
the run time with and without
webassembly simd
and
what i found was really really
interesting where
as you can see the web assembly with
simdi
gives us pretty close to the native cmd
performance but in the browser
which is
really fantastic for those applications
that can benefit from some d
now what's really interesting about this
is that
you know when we compare performance
between javascript and webassembly
one can always argue
well you didn't optimize your javascript
enough and it's not because of the web
assembly that your app is faster
and that could be very true
but
when now we're talking about simd
this is a whole new game
because javascript does not have access
to cmd instructions whereas
webassembly does
and so this is why this is a really
really exciting
advancement i'm looking forward to
seeing that enabled in all the browsers
if you're interested in learning more
about webassembly simd in particular you
can check out my
recent webassembly live talk that is
available on youtube
all right so so far
i focused mostly on how awesome web
assembly is but before we end i i do
want to spend a moment
talking about when
you should not use webassembly
so to me it kind of comes down to three
things
if your app is not compute intensive
enough
or it's too compute intensive
or if webassembly adds too much
complexity to your code then you should
not use webassembly so i want to just
dive into
each of those a little bit deeper
so first if your app is not compute
intensive enough so if it doesn't
involve graphics if it doesn't involve
data processing simulations
audio processing video image you know
all these kinds of compute
heavy tasks for example if you're
building a crud app
just use javascript that's kind of the
idea here
at the other end of the spectrum
if you're trying to do too much compute
intensive work
it's just not going to work in the
browser whether you use webassembly or
not
you know for example if if i'm trying to
assemble
very large genomes in the browsers
it's just not going to work right i'm
going to need
to deploy that
in the cloud where i can have
more hefty compute power
and finally you know
code reuse
and performance
are really nice and all but it's also
important
that we consider the complexity the
webassembly adds to our code base to our
build process
but also to
the maintainability
of the code for
your entire team
right it's it's a bit hard to give
concrete examples here because this will
really depend on your team and how
comfortable they they are with with
introducing something like webassembly
but at the end of the day
webassembly is a really powerful tool
you just have to make sure that the
added complexity
is worth it for your application
all right so that's all i had to share
please check out my book if you're just
getting started with webassembly and
you're looking for a practical guide
i also have a whole bunch of other
articles and videos that you can check
out
and with that i want to thank you very
much for being here